[Music]
imagine a boat is crossing a river from
one bank to another
it's moving in the direction
perpendicular to the flow of the river
tell me will the boat reach the bank at
this place p
or somewhere to the right of it
that's right the boat will reach the
bank somewhere on the right side of this
point b
we know that the motion of the boat is
also influenced by the velocity of the
river
along with the velocity of the boat's
engine
so the boat actually travels with a
different velocity
which is the resultant of these two
velocities
if vector v1 represents the velocity of
the boat's engine
and vector v2 represents the velocity of
the river
then the boat's velocity v3 will be the
vector sum
of these two velocities and what will be
this vector v3
let's find out let's say this arrow
represents vector v1
the velocity of the boat's engine we
know that the reverse velocity is
perpendicular to v1
so let this arrow represent the reverse
velocity v2
now we know intuitively that the vector
v3
which is the boat's actual velocity will
be somewhere in between these two
vectors
but how can we find it accurately
actually to find the vector v3 precisely
there is a law of vector addition called
the parallelogram law of vector addition
now let's suppose that we have a
parallelogram
and the two adjacent sides of it
represent the two vectors
a and b in magnitude and direction like
this
then the sum of the vectors a and b is
represented
in magnitude and direction by the
diagonal of the parallelogram
through the common point this is known
as the parallelogram law of vector
addition
take a moment and have a look at it
now let's get back to our example can
you apply this law here
to find the boat's actual velocity v3
for this let's draw a line segment
parallel vector v1
here and similarly a line segment
parallel to vector v2 here
so since v1 and v2 are perpendicular to
each other
we get a rectangle here now according to
the parallelogram law of vector addition
this diagonal will represent the vector
v3
we can find the magnitude and the
direction of the vector v3
by using the geometric properties of
this rectangle
so in this way we can apply this law to
find the vector sum
of two vectors now suppose we are given
these two vectors
c and d whose initial points are not the
same
can you find their vector sum for this
we will just have to move one of the
vectors parallelly
without affecting its magnitude and
direction
such that the initial point of both the
vectors coincide
if we move vector d then we will get
this now
we draw two lines parallel to vector c
and d to form a parallelogram
then according to the parallelogram law
of vector addition
this diagonal will represent the sum of
the vectors c
and d but now wait in the previous video
we saw that the sum of two vectors is
given by the triangle law of vector
addition
here according to this law we move
vector d
such that its initial point coincides
with the terminal point like this
so we see that these three points abc
will form a triangle now the third side
of the triangle in the opposite order
than these two
represents the vector sum of these two
vectors
thus we have two laws for vector
addition
which one should we follow to find the
vector sum
actually both the laws give us the same
resultant vector
these two laws are equivalent to each
other
we will see this in the next lesson
here we saw how to add vectors
in the next lesson we will also look at
how to subtract two vectors
to stay updated and to keep learning
such interesting concepts
do subscribe to our channel
you